Okay, so let's just get this sorted right off the bat.
A National Geographic article estimates that a Tyrannosaurus Rex's top speed is about 12 miles an hour, any faster and it's bones would have shattered.
In 2013,
a woman ran a 100-meter dash in heels
in a record breaking 14.531 seconds or about 15.4 miles an hour
So, while it may not be easy it would be entirely
feasible to outrun a T-Rex in heels.
So all that fuss around Claire Dearing
doing it in Jurassic World,
100% plausible
The real question is,
why are you driving so slow?
Hello internet, welcome, to Theory Park
[Music]
About a month or two ago
I asked you all on Instagram
@MatPatGT, by the way,
Whether you'd be interested in a Jurassic World theory
and overwhelmingly,
you all said yes,
so today as an early Kwanzaa gift
we'll be sticking our noses into
one of the most overlooked aspects of the movie,
THE PLOT
The whole thing  seems pretty straightforward, right?
InGen mixes a bunch of genes together
to create the freak show of death known as the I-Rex
Or should I say?
"Verizon Wireless presents the Indominus Rex"
[Sighs]
#NotSponAtAll there guys
It's like the Emoji Movie all over again
The I-Rex is too smart for them and escapes,
only to have big dinos running around eating people
for a second time in any of these parks
and humanity still flocks to these deathtrap parks.
It's a miracle that we don't lose the race for survival of the fittest
Then again, I guess a two-hour think piece
on the ethics of dinosaur cloning legislation
would be a terrible movie.
Jurassic Park
Jurassic World
Jurassic United Nations
Anyway, while everyone else watching these movies loses their minds
over whether the kids are gonna become
a Velociraptor's Amuse-bouche
I'm losing my mind over the science.
Because while the Jurassic movies deal with
some fascinating concepts
like genetics splicing and cloning
In Jurassic World,
It actually goes one step further.
If you stop and analyze
the science in the movie
you unearth the fascinating and
completely undiscovered plot line that
Recontextualizes everything
that you're watching unfold on screen
because here's the truth:
The I-Rex doesn't escape on its own.
The whole thing was a setup.
The dinosaur had help.
Let's look at the way the I-Rex escape happens in the movie
During a routine check up on the Indominus,
the infrared cameras monitoring its pen
reveal no heat signature.
This, coupled with claw marks against the walls
lead the team to think that the Indominus Rex has escaped.
Despite the potentially huge security breach
and the ability to call up the control room
and check on the dino's tracker location in a matter of seconds,
Chris Pratt decides to just,
saunter on into the pen
only to find out that,
whoops, the I-Rex had hid its heat signature from the cameras
and was still in there
You done got fooled!
As the humans try to escape,
they leave the door open for the I-Rex to escape
and in the process
set in motion the hilarious line of dominoes
where, by the end,
practically every dinosaur is out
and gnawing on the bones of innocent tourists.
And all they wanted to do was just
educate themselves about the Mesozoic era.
Now, that all begs the question of how
one dinosaur,
genetically modified or no,
was able to hide its heat signature from infrared cameras
and lure its zookeepers into a death trap.
Well, according to the beast's creator,
Dr. Henwy, Wu hen.
HENWY
WU
Well, according to the beast's creator,
Dr. Henry Wu,
the genetic cocktail that makes up the I-Rex
gave the creature some really cool superpowers
like the ability to cloak itself
and the ability to alter its body heat
Dr. Henry Wu: Cuttlefish chains were added to help and withstand an
accelerated growth rate, tree frogs can modulate their infrared output,
we use strands from their DNA to adapt it to a tropical climate. In order for the AI Rex to evade both visual and infrared
detection to trick its captors into the cage,
it would have had to have used both those abilities at once the problem is that is scientifically impossible
Dr. Wu is absolutely right that cuttlefish can change the chromatophores on their skin to create a kind of camouflage and honestly it is super
impressive.
And he's also right that tree frogs can modulate their infrared output
Through their control of body heat so for someone lightly versed in animal biology this explanation totally holds up.
But there's one huge problem here. The I-Rex could not use both abilities at the same time, you see the way the tree frog
regulates their body temperature is by changing colors, darker colors tend to absorb more light,
causing body heat to increase while lighter colors reflect more light,
cooling off the frog, or, in this case mutant dinosaurs. That's all well and good if you don't care
how visible you are,
but if you're currently trying to camouflage
yourself to match your surroundings and avoid visual
detection, you don't also have the luxury of adjusting your body heat the same way a tree frog does.
Dr. Wu is either just flat-out wrong about the science the I-Rex is putting to use, or...
He's lying
Also, just cause I know it's gonna come up in the comments, the fact that everyone reminds us that the I-Rex can:
"They say it can sense thermal radiation, like snakes," doesn't disprove anything. Yes, snakes can sense heat signatures,
they practically have their own built-in thermal vision that they use while hunting,
but that's not going to do all that much to help a hybrid dino disappear from a bunch of surveillance
cameras, the only way for the I-Rex to hatch this entire plan on its own is if, 1. It was able to sense the
electromagnetic waves coming from the cameras in its pen, 2. It had the knowledge those cameras were tracking its heat signature,
3. It had figured out the exact range and sensitivity of those cameras, and 4. It somehow was able to make the connection that those
cameras were specifically being used by the humans to monitor and even if the indominus had human DNA and its genetic
cocktail to give it super intelligence
We know based on a backdoor in the Masrani blog an additional site made by the movies
supposedly written by the CEO of the park that you can hack into it's actually a really cool idea that the movie developed in anticipation
of the launch that the CEO gave the orders to start development of the dinosaur in 2012 this movie takes place in
2015 at the
absolute most
The I-Rex is three years old, no three year old, human
or otherwise is gonna be smart enough to concoct the
I-Rex's plan, so what? Hollywood just dropped the ball on another series of scientific facts.
That's nothing new, but in this case
I don't think it was a mistake at all. If you look closer the evidence points to the cameras having been tampered with. By who?
Well the obvious choice is Vic Hoskins head of in InGen security division throughout the movie
He repeatedly
expresses his desire to give the Raptors a field test to prove that they could be effective weapons in war, "What do you need buddy?"
"Field tests" "Look, nature gave us the most effective killing machines 75 million years ago."
"Jets."
"It's grown-up time," only his request is repeatedly denied by the CEO of the company who shows no
signs of changing his mind despite all the years of work Hoskins has put into the program.
"I've been working for two years on an application for those Raptors. They can hunt, and kill that creature."
"Let me be as clear as I can, no velociraptors are going to be set loose on this island."
It's only after the I-Rex escapes and the CEO dies trying to recapture it that Vic is able to take control of the park
and finally get the field test he was demanding. He sabotages the system so the I-Rex can escape and he gets his field
test when everyone else denied him. Everything lines up, everything, except for one line.
He's surprised when the I-Rex escapes hey. "Hey yeah, it's me.
We might have an opportunity here."
So it may not have been
Vic, but there was one other person
involved with this conspiracy
that also stands to benefit from the field test, the creator of the I-Rex and most of the other dinos in the park, the
secret villain of the entire series, Doctor Henry Wu.
At the end of the film Hoskins begins revealing his plan only to get himself rudely interrupted
Should have had Henry breed in some etiquette there Vic
But before he becomes just a meat fleck between some raptor teeth he confirms that Dr. Wu wasn't working for MS
Ronnie in the park, rather InGen and its goal of developing dinosaurs as weapons "Dr. Wu, he works for us."
"Somebody's got to make sure that this company has a future," in fact as Wu evacuates the island in the Indian
helicopter we hear him specifically ask
Dr. Wu clearly had to deal with Vick Hoskins tied to the I-Rex
But it's likely that that deal was contingent on proving the combat effectiveness of the dinosaur
And there was no way to do that while it was locked inside of its paddock.
They had to find a way to release it
But why, why would we want this chaos?
Well remember a recurring theme through the whole movie is that the park is quickly losing money.
In the clip we just saw Vic said how he's ensuring that the company has a future the opening moments have the employees including Dr.
Wu trying to win over
potential investors and in the first conversation with the parks owner the CEO just completely brushes aside any financial concerns
"I care nothing about costs; spare no expense."
The company is going downhill in fact "While year-over-year revenue continues to climb,
operating costs are higher than ever our shareholders have been patient, but let's be honest. No one's impressed by a dinosaur anymore."
Dr. Wu sees himself as a scientific genius
"All of this exists,
because of me," and from the secret website files we learned that he received
international fame the last time he created a genetic hybrid and that was only him creating a plant. In short, Dr.
Wu sees himself as a god.
That's not me talking that is literally the name of the book that he wrote, "The Next Step: An Evolution of God's Concepts"
But all that goes away if the company goes away. No more job equals no more research equals no more faith.
He sees the writing on the wall he sees investments in the amusement park down, costs rising, and the CEO being
unconcerned about all of it. So he started to make alternate plans.
A deal with Vic Hoskins and the higher-ups at InGen to not only secure his own future
but more importantly the future of his research. Except all of it hinged on a real-life test of the
dinosaurs a test that only happened because one of those dinosaurs found some miraculous
unbelievable way of escaping or maybe it was Wu himself making that miracle happen helping to give the Indominus the little push it needed to
escape which brings us all the way back around to the science remember, It's Dr.
Wu who comes up with the false science behind how the I-Rex manages to escape. The man is a brilliant geneticist
if he knows that tree frogs can modulate their temperature. He knows that it depends on the frogs coloration
He knows that the I-Rex couldn't evade both types of cameras. Now look at how this moment was shot. Wu has his back
to Masrani. It's clearly a purposeful choice because in this moment Dr. Wu is
absolutely lying, he's the one who sabotaged the cameras, allowing the Indominus Rex to escape,
proving that the scariest monster in Jurassic world is
mankind itself, but hey, that's just a theory, a film theory,
and cut.
By the way,
you know how animals are pretty much all either
warm-blooded like mammals or
cold-blooded like reptiles well right now scientists think that dinosaurs might be in the middle they, might be able to regulate their own body temperature.
It's actually called mesothermic. Sea turtles and a few sharks can also do it apparently. Anyway
I just thought it was a funny thing to bring up since it means that the
I-Rex would just be able to modulate its body temperature naturally none of this weird genetic splicing explanation, necessary
anyway,
speaking of dinosaurs take a big ol bite out of that subscribe button where you can bet that I have more theories on the way
as we get closer to the next Jurassic movie coming next year. Hey if you want more Dino analysis
then check out my game theory on Jurassic World where I examine whether you could actually clone a dinosaur from DNA
extracted from amber the answer is gonna surprise you. Now if you'll excuse me
I'm starting to feel a little bit of Juras-sick if you get what I'm saying, so I'm gonna lay down.
Uh, hopefully I feel better for next week. See you then!